I am sister pbilic say I am 45 years old  and I live in Victoria's negros  occidental  I can eat anything that's why I can even  go to the mission because I whatever is  being in front of me are offered to me I  can eat them  in the center where I I'm staying  Mary help of Christian school it's an  agricultural farm and our agricultural  school most of them are indigenous  people coming to our places and although  we assist them after they study in our  school the possibility of earning for  the living is not that very very strong  and they have the difficulty of putting  into market other products I am a  teacher I I also am an animator in this  in the center but I am not earning  anything  Jews  I have a leisure time with the Lord I  pray and maybe this is also where I I  took my strength and my source to be  able to help others